paul blackburn his 20th big league start
of his career just the second of the
2021 campaign you remember
called up after chris bassett was bit by
that comebacker he went five and a third
against chicago last time out three
earned runs just 75 pitches
not this time as blackburn strikes it
out good evening for paul blackburn gets
the ground out a fly out and a strikeout
here come the a's when we come back
up on the mount tonight for the mariners
it is marco gonzalez who has been
brilliant by and large in the second
half this season now he's really pitched
well lately the 17 stars five and five
record a 4-1 era for
hitting the corners
bounced in the left field and that's a
base hit
and that olson was down in the count oh
and two and
didn't seem too worried about that he
just put bat on the ball and rolled it
in the left field
runners go and the pitch is outside the
throw to second safe so it's a double
steal
gomes took a close pitch
thrown through to second base
so these
stealing more bags and instead of that
foot coming up over the bag right into
it
bounced up the middle it's going to get
a run home
carl throws out
john gomes so the stolen base in this
case the double steal helps the a's get
a run but we have seen that quite a bit
down the left field line and it drops in
for a base hit toro makes a wide turn at
second and retreats
kellnick a two out single that has to
feel good snaps an old for 20 for the
young center fielder
and that one
past gomes and both runners will move up
having to reach across and
give it a stab
maybe not enough time to get down and
get around and block that pitch and that
one's hit well martay got to hustle back
now he's still going back and marty
makes the catch so
speed helps marte used it there a couple
of runners stranded for the mariners
bottom of the second coming up one
nothing
[Applause]
and right field
powers gets a start there tonight and he
makes the catch marco retires the side
in order out of the third here is
blackburn back up on the mound facing
9-1-2 jake bowers leads it off
fights this one through
lead off-base hit for jake bowers
[Applause]
[Music]
toward right field
pinder's back
pender says i got it and he does so lead
off single nothing else
nice job so far by paul blackburn
one-nothing a's as we go to the bottom
of the third 0-2-1-2 when he wants a
pitch he will move well off the plate he
doesn't want him to make a mistake in an
o2 count
oh chasing feet off the plate
martay fishing round number three marco
retires the last eight straight
playing those good teams is important
playing teams that are hot at the right
time playing good baseball at the right
time just as important strike three
called on the inside corner
four strikeouts for paul blackburn so
here's fraley with two outs
the shift on
dive up throw freiley's out
so jed lowry with a very nice diving
play to his left takes a hit away from
fraley
and it's a three-up three-down inning
six in a row retired by paul blackburn
gonzalez has a career record against the
athletics of six and three
[Applause]
that one's it deep to left field fraley
going back freley turning around and
that baby's gone
young
giving lefties fits for quite a while
now
change up center cut
goes 325 is his batting average
against left-handed pitching
alice hits one in the air to right
hinders there waiting
he's got it
nine in a row retired by paul blackburn
we're going to the bottom of the fifth
two nothing games
the 11th
pitch to seeger
[Applause]
two gone
this will be the sixth pitch to
elvis andrews
he swings through it up above the zone
marco has sat down 14 of the last 15
hitters faced
moving down in the zone that's why he's
a ground ball pitcher but he also mixed
in his cutter curveball change up
let's find center field
j.p crawford a lead off single snaps
nine in a row retired by blackburn the
mariners
have something going here in the sixth
inning for henniger and seeger
tyne run at the plate
a hangar
mashed out to left center tied game
number 29 mitch haniger brings us right
back where we started
maybe hannigan's starting to heat up a
little bit this third homer this trip
man that cuts through a cold night by
the bay
and he got a curveball
for blackburn
after giving up the hanniger homer
strikes out cedar bob melvin's coming
out and he's going to take the baseball
from paul blackburn he goes five and two
thirds innings tonight gives it the
homer to haninger but that's it
[Applause]
check swing
j finn has no play and toro is aboard
man when it is working it is working
buries the breaking ball in the dirt
i did not realize it bounced first and
then hit his bat
i didn't either oh
i mean that went from that's incredible
that went from oh man to that's just a
screaming rocket two outs and here comes
matt olson wind down the pitch
slow curve hit high in the air deep
right center field bowers on the run to
the track at the wall and out it goes
for matt olsen
number 32
and the a's are back ahead 3-2 a
majestic drive to deep right center a
much-needed blow for the a's
[Applause]
pitch here it is
and he got a breaking ball
bauer strikes out a very good inning for
andrew chapin couple strikeouts seventh
inning stretch time coming up
over the years he can get wild only
three blown saves this year
[Applause]
clubbed how far is this carrying back
and he has done it again
back to back ninth inning shots to tie
it up who else would it be
ty france
this finds left field mariners take the
lead for the first time toro and
fraley's score
jake bowers puts the mariners in front
five to three
last chance for the a's now is harrison
seawall it's 2-2 hey got him right there
at the top shelf
seawall slams the door again and the
mariners get what is becoming
a textbook mariners win
you